hi I'm Seth MacFarlane and I've got some
very very big news and I've invited my
father over today because I want him to
be the first to know I have been asked
to host the 85th Annual Academy Awards
Wow
isn't that great pretty amazing that I'm
I'm overwhelmed with excitement Elysion
thank you yeah big news yeah anyway
listen I brought you these these bathing
suits and I want you to have them they
don't fit me anymore obviously I don't
really need bathing their beautiful
bathing suit
they're barely used here I don't I'm not
take them take them I warm only once and
I had on underwear underneath there so
nothing of importance ever touch than
this I've invited you here today to tell
you I'm hosting the Oscars there should
be huge news to you of course it's
wonderful news but also the fact that
you're getting almost brand new bathing
suits is also good news and I think a
thank you is an order fine fine thank
you thank you for these Wow three new
bathing suits or kind of new this is all
issue a press release give me those
I'm gonna give these to Billy Crystal